Musik Bitte, Mann, doch schön, aber auch mal zu guter schön.
Hey und hallo, herzlich willkommen zu der neuen Ausgabe des Das-Podcast-Ufo-Podcast-Projektes im Jahre 2021 mit mir, Stefan Tietze und dir, Florettin Will.
Und natürlich mir gegenüber sitzt wie immer Stefan Tietze, gut eingepackt, gut eingewickelt, schön hat sich in seine Umgebung eingefügt, als wäre er da geboren worden. Ich bin heute mit Halsschmerzen aufgewacht und dachte dann kurz, muss ich jetzt auch mit einem Schal und so dick eingepackt, obwohl das Wetter noch nicht gebietet, rumlaufen, weil es so gang und gäbe ist. Es gehört zum guten Ton quasi, wenn man Halsschmerzen hat, direkt halt die Augenlider die ganze Zeit so ein bisschen so halb müde runterhängen zu lassen, um mit so einem dicken Schal rumzulaufen. Du musst es auch tragen können. Also nicht jedem steht eine Erkältung, aber ich glaube, du bist jemand, der das tragen kann. Also dieser lange Schal, dieses Thermometer im Mund, dann dieses Eis auf dem Kopf oder dieser Eisbeutel auf dem Kopf. Weiß man nicht genau, was es ist? Keine Ahnung, ich glaube, das ist ein Look, der dir steht. Und das ist wirklich so ein Set auch. Das kann man als ein Set kaufen und so gehört sich das auch, wenn du erkältst. Be cranky. Ja, wie cranky oder der Grinch, einfach so. Be cranky. Du hast dann die Handschuhe, du hast den Kopf, du hast die Schminke, ist auch dabei. Alles ist dabei. So eine rote Nase. Ja. Für diese Österreich und Schnieferinchen kommen da in den Sinn. Absolut, ja, die natürlich auf der aktuellen Erkältungswelle Cash, Cash, Cash machen. Surfen. Die da auch surfen, aber leider noch nicht in Druck gegangen sind. Es gibt da mehrere lizenzrechtliche Probleme, aber anscheinend kann man nicht die menschliche Nase lizenzieren. Wir haben versucht, die menschliche Nase copyrightmäßig zu schützen für unser Kinderbuch. So eine Bildmarke für die Nase. Und dann haben wir viele böse Mails bekommen, im Sinne der zu vage, zu unspezifisch und so ein Fachchinesisch. Ja, ja, genau. Also lauter so Anwaltsblabla. Und ja, stellt sich raus, wir können die Nase nicht lizenzieren. Wir wollten ja als Logo und einfach ein Profil der Nase. Aber geht nicht anscheinend. Kann man nicht machen und jetzt müssen wir uns was anderes belegen. Vielen Dank in diesem Zuge auch an Mike für das Intro, der nicht sagt krank, krank, krank, schlechte Laune, Winter. Nein, der boxt sich durch. Der boxt sich durch, holt die Steeldrums raus aus dem Keller, verstaubt die verstaubte Steeldrums, pustet nochmal drüber und haut auf die Steeldrums drauf und hat diese sommerliche Intro komponiert. Toll, vielen Dank Mike. Danke Mike, aber das ist immer der traurigste Moment eines jeden Steeldrums-Künstlers, wenn man sie dann doch in den Keller packt. Wenn man dann doch nach den guten 14 Minuten Spaß, die man hatte mit den Steeldrums, sie dann doch letztendlich in den Keller packt und dann verstauben lässt zu den anderen Sachen. Da herrscht, finde ich, ein grosser Disconnect zwischen Name und Sound. Weil Steeldrum sagt eigentlich Hard Rock, Metal, ist aber dieses fröhliche Sommer, anders als Bongos, die ziemlich genau aussagen, was sie sagen. Ja, auch Conga, du weißt einfach, das ist kein Heavy Metalstrument. Du weißt einfach, das ist ein bisschen flockig locker.
Du weißt, was du bekommst. Kastagnetten. Passt auch. It's a match. Steel Drum? Es klingt wie nach Heavy Metal, Rammstein.
Nein, es ist feuchtfröhliches Rumgesommer. Es gibt hundertprozentig auch eine Metal-Band, die mit Steel Drums spielt. Ich habe letztens immer mal wieder gerne diese Seite entdeckt, diese Every Noise, irgendwas, Painting, Every Noise Painting, wo du so eine riesige Textdatei hast, mit allen Musikgenres der Welt. Und es gibt ja eine Million Genres der Welt, also da gibt es dann irgendwie Synthi-Pop, Japanese Pop-Synthi, Jazz, Synthi-Jazz-Metal, Metal-Jazz, Reggae-M Jazz, Reggae, Metal, Metal, Reggae, Reggae, Reggae, Reggae, Susphir. Alles. Und dann kannst du da draufklicken und dann hörst du da so ein Hörbeispiel. Ah ja, ja, ja. Und dann aus dem Allgäu irgendwie Blas, Cover von Liquido und ganz merkwürdig. Und ich bin nämlich auf der Suche nach meinem Musikgeschmack. Ich kann dir nicht sagen, weil wenn du jetzt sagst, okay, welche Musik hört Stefan? Punk Rock, New Metal, Limbiscuit, New Pagadi, da bist du zu Hause. Aber bei mir, ich kann das einfach nicht so, ich mag manchmal hier, ich mag manchmal hier, ich mag manchmal hier, aber ich habe noch nicht so meinen eigenen Musikgeschmack gefunden. Wenn ich mich frage, ist die Musikrichtung Soundtrack eine Musikrichtung, ein Genre?
Ja, das ist die Frage.
Ich habe bei Spotify eine Playlist gemacht, Soundtracks, und das sind teilweise keine guten Songs, aber ich bin fröhlich, wenn ich die höre, weil ich die mit den jeweiligen Filmen verbinde. Und irgendwie macht das ja auch Sinn. Also das ist kein, die haben keinen gemeinsamen Nenner, ausser dass sie in Filmen stattfinden, die ich mag. Sehr unterschiedlichen Filmen. Sehr unterschiedliche Filme, du hast teilweise Rom-Coms, teilweise Horror mit drin. Ja, es sind super fröhliche Pop-Songs, so auch die Serie Love zum Beispiel da drin. Ist aber auch so ein Tarantino Girl, You'll Be a Woman Soon, David Bowie. Also es passt jetzt nicht zusammen. Und diese Playlist hat gar keinen roten Faden, außer dass ich irgendwann beim Filmgucken oder Seriegucken dachte, oh, das kann man sich mal merken. Und irgendwie ist es aber eine Playlist, die ich doll mag, weil ich glaube, mein Gehirn connectet dann immer diese Musik mit den Szenen, die ich sehr mochte. Und das hilft ja manchmal. Aber es muss doch für jeden Menschen eine Musikrichtung geben. Es gibt so viele Musikrichtungen auf der Welt. Gibt es mehr Musikrichtungen als Menschen? Auf jeden Fall. Du kannst ja noch alle kombinieren. Es sei dann alles noch mal kombinierbar. Es muss doch für mich einen dieser Namen geben, hinter denen einfach meine Leidenschaft steckt. Aber ich habe sie noch nicht gefunden, auch wenn ich oft draufklicke. Ich wollte gerade eine App empfehlen. Ich finde sie leider nicht mehr auf meinem Handy, weil ich zu viele Apps habe. Die heißt Tinder, damit du mal nicht den ganzen Tag alleine. Damit du mal ein bisschen mehr Zeit mit anderen Menschen bringst auch. Ne, und zwar heisst diese App Radio. Und zwar Radio und dann darf ich fünf Os. Fünf Os. So, und du hast ... War vier Os schon besetzt? Und diese App ist perfekt für dich, glaube ich, weil du bist ja gerade zwanghaft auf der Suche nach der Musik, die dir gefällt. Ja. So, du hast eine Weltkarte für diese Musik und einen Zeitstreifen. 1920 bis jetzt, 2020. Okay. So, Und du kannst dann das Jahrzehnt auswählen und irgendwo auf diese Karte drücken und du kriegst dann quasi so Top Tracks, radio-mässig, aus dem Jahrzehnt, aus dem Land gespielt. Wow, das ist ja wirklich das ultimative Hipster-Tool, wenn du sagst, ich höre eigentlich nur Musik aus den Sechzigern, die in Helsinki bekannt waren. Genau.. Alles südlich davon interessiert mich ja gar nicht. Alles südlich von Helsinki habe ich keinen Bezug zu. Wenn mal ein Silvester, was dann rückblickend nicht schön war, weil wir das zu lange gemacht haben. Aber für so, ich sag mal, das ist sowas für Silvester und dann so eine gute halbe Stunde, wo du dann einen Menschen an deiner Party fragst, ja, Jahr zehnt, und der andere Mensch fragst nach einem Land. Und dann drückst du drauf und du hast halt Songs, die du auf jeden Fall noch nicht gehört hast. Es ist ein guter zweiter Akt der Party. Nach dem Kennenlernen und Awkwardness kommt der zweite Akt, lustige Spiele, die dann zu Musik führen, zu hoffentlich dem dritten Akt, ich gehe früher nach Hause. So, das ist dann die Konklusion einer jeden Party. Aber für den zweiten Akt, glaube ich, ist es richtig gut. Genau, wenn du jetzt aber Kasachstan 1930 machst, ist es auch ein guter dritter Akt, ganz am Ende, wenn du willst, dass der Abend endet. Das ist so das kleine Geheimnis unter DJs. Wenn du willst, dass die Party zu Ende ist, geh Richtung Kasachstan. Je näher du in Kasachstan bist, desto mehr gehen die Leute nach Hause. Wobei, ja, wahrscheinlich ist Kasachachstan gar nicht richtig, weil Kasachstan ist ja auch spannend irgendwie ungehört. Aber ich glaube so ein Bad-Taste-Land, so Holland 1940. Ach so, das weiß ich nicht. Holland 1940 los war, ich glaube, die hatten andere Probleme als die Musikcharts. Ja, mach mal Holland 1940.
Ja.
Mal kurz an.
Das sind die deutschen Panzer, Stefan, die man hat.
Okay.
Ich würde sagen, es ist eher Rauschmeister-Musik. Es ist eher, ja, ich glaube,
ich muss mal gucken, ob mein Auto noch im Halteverbot steht.
Und ich muss, danke an alle, haut rein, meinen Twitter-Handle habe ich euch ja gegeben und ich wäre dann jetzt bereit.
Man darf, wenn alle rausgehen, dann darf man die Tür aber nicht so lange offen halten, weil dann kommen so Charleston-Tanzend Leute rein.
Ja, immer die Treppen, auch die lieben Treppen immer hoch und runter und am Geländer rutschend sind die hoch und runter. Es ist einfach furchtbar. Ich kann Radio sehr empfehlen. Ja. Und was ich auch sehr empfehlen kann, so an Party Musik spielen, ist Shazam. Und zwar der Reihe nach, entweder die letzten Shazam, also was man zuletzt Shazamt hat, weil natürlich hörst du dann nicht immer nur Songs, die Leuten gefallen, sondern du hast immer auch gleich so eine Szene im Kopf, wie derjenige, diejenige irgendwo diesen Song gehört und dachte, das ist mir jetzt, entweder reinsingt, entweder reinsingt oder irgendwo sitzt oder steht und nicht anders kann, als diesen Song sich jetzt zu merken. Diesen Song will ich nicht verlieren.
Ich muss das konservieren.
Dieser Song war der Person so wichtig,
dass sie im Club das Handy an den Lautsprecher
gehalten hat und gesagt hat, ich will das jetzt für immer wissen.
Können wir alle die Fresse halten kurz, damit ich das kurz
versetzen kann. Es ist Toxic, du Trottel!
Ah, ja, danke!
Ah, ja!
Bei mir sind es auch Hälfte neue Songs
und Hälfte alte Songs, auf dessen Namen ich nicht gekommen bin. Und Hälfte Tom Steiner. Und die App so, oh, come on, es ist Tom Steiner, jeden Tag dieser Song. Die App sollte eigentlich immer, meinten Sie Tom Steiner anzeigen, sind defaultmäßig. Schon bevor man anfängt zu singen, einfach Tom Steiner. Das ist so, wie wenn du im Gitarrenladen den ganzen Tag Stayway to Heaven hörst. So muss diese fucking Shazam-App den ganzen Tag, wie war das noch, du du du du du du du aus, einfach disconnect. I got coffee in the morning, got coffee in the morning, got coffee in the morning, got coffee in the morning. Sitting in the diner, waving through the window. Also, ich glaube, das ist wirklich der Text, weiß ich aber nicht genau. Das ist ja so, wie ich damals in meiner Bandzeit Texte geschrieben habe. Hast du da noch Texte aus deiner alten Bandzeit? Gibt es noch unveröffentlichte Binky-Sack-Boo-Hits, die jetzt vielleicht durch den richtigen Dubstep-Beat vielleicht noch mal zeitgemäß veröffentlicht werden können? Nee, es wurde alles gnadenlos ausgeschlachtet, um irgendwie diese halbe Stunde, die wir Auftrittszeit hatten, vollzubekommen. Weil das ist auch lang, ehrlich zu sagen. Es ist lang. Boah, ist das lang, da muss man ganz schön viel Musik machen. Es kann die längste halbe Stunde deines Lebens sein. Nee, von daher wurde alles gnadenlos ausgeschlchlagen. Es gab keinen Text, der nicht für irgendwas
verwendet und noch mal verwendet
wurde. Also deine ganze Schulaufsätze,
deine Tagebucheinträge, alles
zweitverwendet, drittverwendet. Da habe ich ja grosse Angst,
dass man wie Prince irgendwann
dann stirbt und dann zerren
die Verwandten noch so Sachen,
die man ja aus gutem Grund nicht veröffentlicht
hat, hervor
und verschachern die dann.
Und jetzt, weiß ich nicht, rütteln die so ein bisschen an dem
Kunstwerk Prince.
Also, es ist schon ein bisschen gemeint. Ich meine, wir haben auch noch 400 Podcast-Folgen rumliegen, die wir nicht veröffentlicht haben. Das wäre nicht in unserem Interesse, wenn die veröffentlicht werden würden, überhaupt nicht. Nein. Kannst du nicht ins Testament schreiben, Leute halt auf meinen Scheiß zu veröffentlichen, ich habe das aus gutem Grund nicht veröffentlicht? Ja, jetzt muss man das ins Testament schreiben oder kann man nicht so viel von seinen Verwandten erwarten? Ich habe letztens gehört, was im Testament steht, muss man nicht unbedingt machen. Also du kannst nicht ins Testament schreiben, wenn ich sterbe, bitte bring meine Nichte um. Weil dann sagst du, ja, ich bin rechtlich gebunden, ich muss das tun. Aber der Richter sagt, nee, Testament ist auch nicht so wichtig. Aber das ist eher dramaturgisch Hollywood-mässig. Eigentlich ist das nicht so wichtig, was da drin ist. Es ist mehr so ein Einkaufszettel, wo man vielleicht das ein oder andere als Inspiration nimmt, aber es ist nicht rechtlich bindend.
Testamente sind nicht rechtlich bindend?
Und ja, ich will ungern jetzt eine zu klare Aussage treffen, weil sonst die Leute kommen dann immer und sagen, ja, was ist, wenn ich reinschreibe, nach meinem Tod will ich, dass eine Million Dollar in meinem Namen an diese Stiftung gespendet werden? Und woher kommen die dann? Also bitte tun Sie mir den Gefallen und hören Sie auf, Fragen zu stellen. Sie sind so ein vager Anwalt. Ja, was heißt Anwalt? Wie war Ihr Name nochmal? Können Sie mich bitte nicht Anwalt nennen, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen, sagen wir, ein guter Kumpel. Okay, wie war Ihr Name nochmal? Wie war Ihr Name nochmal? Walter. Wieso? Und deswegen wäre es gut, wenn Sie keine weiteren Fragen stellen. Ihr Testament, ich kümmere mich drum, Ihre Podcasts werden nicht veröffentlicht, Ihr Tagebuch bleibt sicher bei mir. Und dann nach Ihrem Tod, das ist alles in Ordnung. Das passt schon. Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen. In Ihrem Testament steht, Sie wollen hundertprozentig sicher gehen, dass Sie wirklich tot sind.
Ich möchte bitte nicht lebendig begraben werden, steht dreimal drin. Das heißt, wir werden dafür sorgen, Sie werden erstochen als Leiche, um sicher zu gehen, dass Sie wirklich tot sind. Das werde ich persönlich, ihr werdet persönlich ihren Leib durchstechen mit, Ich habe einen Katana zu Hause bei mir im Büro.
Das kann ich verwenden, mit dem bin ich geübt.
Ich kann damit einen tödlichen Stoss setzen, wenn das nötig wäre, wenn Ihre Leichnam das noch erhält. Und meine Nichte stirbt. Die bringen Sie dann um, wenn ich gestorben bin.
So, und jetzt sind wir, ja, das ist leider rechtlich nicht ganz, ich kann es versuchen, ich kann es versuchen.
Es ist aber nicht rechtlich binden, dass ich es unbedingt erfüllen muss. Sie können aber scheitern bei dem Versuch. Ich kann in der Form scheitern, dass ich den Termin, dass ich es halt vergessen habe oder den Termin verschoben hat oder mir halt was dazwischen gekommen ist. Das kann ich Ihnen anbieten. Ich bringe Ihre Nichte um, sollte nicht etwas Dringenderes dazwischen kommen. Okay, so können wir das gerne ins Testament aufnehmen. Gut, dann schreiben wir es so rein. Also dann, ich habe es ja aufgenommen. Aber das Testament wird schon ein bisschen dick jetzt mit diesen ganzen Verklausulierungen und Fußnoten. Ohnehin, vielleicht können wir da auch einen Podcast machen, einen Testament-Podcast, dass wir das alles einsprechen können. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen handlicher. Oh, gute Idee. Gute Idee. Du triffst dich mit random Leuten auf der Strasse und sagst, wollen wir zusammen ihr Testament durchgehen? Und die Leute sagen, nee, natürlich nicht, wer sind sie überhaupt? Und dann hast du 400 Folgen, wo 400 Passanten sagen, nee, ich bin gerade auf dem Weg zum Baumarkt. Ich bin gerade auf dem Sprung. Ich bin gerade auf dem Sprung und dann sage ich, wohin denn? Und daraus entwickelt sich vielleicht ein interessantes Gespräch, Was wollen Sie denn bauen im Bauma? Oh, aber Talking with Strangers finde ich eigentlich einen guten Podcast. Also will ich einfach mit fremden Menschen reden, die man einfach anquasselt. Aber das sind keine echten Fremden, oder? Es ist dann doch immer Jörg Pilawa und er hat doch einiges, einige Showbusiness-Stories. Nee, brauchst du gar nicht mit deinem Grinsen, die jetzt hier mich so aus der Reserve locken wollen. Nee, ich will Fremde und auf meinem T-Shirt steht diese Wenn sie mit mir reden, darf ich sie auch aufnehmen. Da ist so ein Loophole auf meinem Shirt. Das heißt, wenn die mit mir quatschen, dann darf ich die auch aufnehmen. Da läuft die ganze Zeit so ein Mikrofon mit und ich sage Talking with Strangers. Ja, und dann kommt zufällig Paul Panzer und spricht dich an und sagt, hey, hier bin ich, ich habe ein paar Gags vorbereitet.
Ja, wenn das Paul Panzer.
Natürlich.
Oder Jörg Pilawa, Irgendwer mit P.
Okay.
Ich habe ein überdurchschnittlich gutes Gedächtnis für Namen mit P.
Hauen zehn raus.
Oli P.
Oli P, Oliver Pocher.
Oliver Pocher, Klaus Paul Panzer, Prokofiev, Sergei Prokofiev, Sergei Papadopoulos, Peter Pan, Paul, der Maulwurf, kenne ich noch? Ist das ein Maulwurf? Pauli, der Maulwurf. Das ist echt ein Maulwurf. Nee, das ist nicht so ein Molch oder so ein Zeichentrickfigur. Das ist kein echter Maulwurf. Der kleine Maulwurf. Ähm, Pepito, Pinocchio, Pinocchio. Ich hätte gerne einen Pinocchio-Becher bitte, und Heinrich Petersen.
Und so geht es mir, wenn ich nach irgendwas ...
Hast du gesehen, I'm talking with a stranger podcast.
Ja, ich habe 16 Kinder.
Pauline, Palando. Warum ist es so, wenn man nach irgendwas gefragt wird, was sind deine Lieblingsfilme, fällt mir Inglorious Bastards ein, das war's, fertig, das war's, keine andere. Um ehrlich zu sein, ich antworte mit auf die Frage, was ist dein Lieblings-X, nicht mit was ist mein Lieblings-X, sondern was ist das einzige X, das mir gerade einfällt, zu dem ich mental Zugang habe. Was ist dein Lieblingsessen? Hotdog. Und ehrlich gesagt, wenn du mich fragst und ich antworte, ist die Chance, dass ich diesen Film gar nicht gesehen habe, sehr gross, weil ich wahrscheinlich gerade an einen Film denke, den ich gucken will, nächste Woche oder so. Ich habe so eine Liste mit so Filmen, die ich noch mal gucken will. So, und die kreisen mir eher im Kopf rum, als die Filme, die ich gesehen habe. Das heißt, es kann gut sein, dass ich einfach lüge und sage, nee, Moneyball. Ja, weil du gerade an Moneyboy gedacht hast, weil du gerade sein Album runterlädst, das ist einfach riesengroß, das dauert, aber es stimmt schon auch, ich nenne auch oft Filme und dann merke ich, nee, ich habe die verwechselt, das ist nicht Spaceballs, das ist Space Jam. Space Jam. Und dann scheiße. Und dann, nee, Starballs, wie heißt diese Star-Wars-Parodie? Traumschiff. Spaceballs. Ja, und den finde ich halt richtig cool, richtig geil. Wie oft lügst du, wenn jemand fragt, wenn man jetzt über Filme redet, den hast du ja gesehen. Ja, ständig. 50 Prozent, nahezu 50 Prozent. Nahezu 50 Prozent. Und bei den anderen 50 Prozent sagst du, nee, habe ich nicht gesehen? Bei den anderen 50 Prozent sage ich, habe ich vor langer Zeit gesehen. Ah ja, nee. Und damit nicht klar ist, damit Gedächtnislücken erklärbar sind direkt. Dann ist bei mir, kommt auch die Person an, wenn ich das Gefühl habe, ich komme schlecht weg, gerade mit meinem Filmwissen, lüge ich zu 70 Prozent. Dann ist es 10 Prozent, es ist zu lange her und die restlichen 20 Prozent gebe ich offen zu, dass ich sie nicht geguckt habe. Aber die meiste Zeit sage ich, ah ja, ja klar, weil man kann sich so gut durch Bullshit. Absolut, ich habe oft auch schon Filme angeschaut und sie nur deswegen gut gefunden, weil ich eine Woche davor mit jemandem darüber gesprochen habe und gesagt habe, ich finde den Film gut. Und ich dachte mir, ich kann jetzt nicht den Film anschauen. Und den Scheiße finden. Und den Scheiße finden, um dann zu sagen, du, Stefan, pass auf, wir haben doch vor zwei Wochen haben wir doch über Break on Me gesprochen. Ja. Ich fand den doch nicht gut. Ja. Also ich habe ja gesagt, ich fand den gut, aber ich fand den doch nicht gut. Ja, das passiert ja nicht. Retour. Storno, ich würde gerne nochmal einen Storno einlegen. Ein Beispiel, dass mir das so einfällt, ist, ich war irgendwie, da war ich so 14 oder sowas und ich war auf so einer merkwürdigen europäischen Klassenfahrt. Dauert es so lange, das alles zu erklären. Jedenfalls Also ich glaube, eine europäische Klassenfahrt reicht. Flashforward. Nee, nee, nee. Ich war mit einem Griechen, der auf einem Zimmer. Wir waren beide, wir wurden beide eingeteilt. Grieche, Rabbi und der Papst und ich sind auf dem Zimmer. Nee, es war ein Grieche und ich haben das Zimmer geteilt und wir haben beide und ich habe nicht gut Englisch gesprochen damals und es war wirklich so 14, 15 oder so was, das war so ein europäischer Austauschkram und er wollte duschen gehen morgens und hat mich gefragt, do you mind if I go showering, bla bla bla bla, alles sehr schlecht im Englisch und ich habe gesagt, yes, gemeint nee, bitte geh, gesagt, ja, mir macht's was aus. I mind indeed. Indeed, I do mind, Sir, Mr. Greek Guy. So, was ihn dazu veranlasst hat, zu lachen und zu sagen, what? Und ich habe gesagt, das ist ein bisschen so, wie man hat erst eine Meinung entwickelt und dann muss man auch dementsprechend handeln. Du sagst, du fattest den Film gut, dann guckst du den Film und musst ihn gut finden. Jetzt musste ich, weil ich eine Arschloch-Antwort gegeben habe, ja, du darfst jetzt nicht duschen gehen. Nee, du darfst deinen Bluff nicht aufdecken. So musste ich Arschloch-mäßig handeln. Heißt, weil ich wollte so sehr geliebt werden in diesem Moment oder gemocht werden, anerkannt werden, dass ich nicht zugeben wollte, einen englischen Fehler gemacht zu haben in der englischen Sprache und habe deswegen mich verhalten wie ein Riesenarschloch gesagt. Yes, I do mind, I wanna go showering first, habe ich dann gesagt. Weil ich, hey, ich wollte lieber ein arrogantes Arschloch sein.
Ja, als schlecht Englisch können.
Als schlecht Englisch können.
Ja, nicht schlecht, okay.
Aber dann dachte ich nachher, was sagt das über mich aus? Ich habe ein grösseres Problem damit, dumm empfunden zu werden, als Arschloch. Du willst ein kluges Arschloch sein. Ich bin lieber ein kluges Arschloch. Das ist dein Ziel, ich will ein kluges Arschloch sein. Als ein, ja, als ein freundlicher fucking Idiot. Und ich glaube, die Chancen stehen nicht schlecht, dass man sich auch so an dich erinnern wird. Stefan Tietze, er war immer ein kluges Arsch. Ein kluges Arsch. Ihr könnt das auch gerne auf ihren Grabstein meißeln lassen. Kein Problem, Herr Tietze. Aber das finde ich schon eine gute Idee, einfach zu sagen yes und dann einfach, der konnte dann die ganze Woche nicht duschen. Einfach weil er sich auch nicht getraut hat, zu fragen, was das Problem ist. Und ja. Aber dann hat es sich irgendwie verpufft, diese Situation, weil er ist dann einfach duschen gegangen und hat es dann wieder als Scherz. Und er ist dann doch vor dir duschen gegangen. Er ist doch vor dir duschen gegangen. Und dann hast du gesagt, jetzt muss ich es aber auch bis zum Ende bringen und ihn aus der Dusche zerren und notfalls mit ihm gemeinsam duschen. Genau, dann waren wir drei Jahre zusammen und aber nee, und dann hat es sich irgendwie, ist er verpufft, weil er ist einfach duschen gegangen, hat es so weggelacht und hat mich, glaube ich, für einen lustigen, für einen klugen, lustigen Menschen gehalten und dann dachte ich irgendwie, aha, das war Weg C, den ich vorher nicht hätte kommen sehen, dass es vielleicht so eine Arschloch-Antwort ist, die man gar nicht so unbedingt jetzt einordnet als Wahrheit, sondern als Scherz. Ja, finde ich gar nicht schlecht. Das ist eine gute Idee. Finde ich gut, dass zumindest diese eine Grieche dich kurzzeitig mochte. Falls er zuhört gerade, falls du zuhörst, ich würde gerne die Geschichte auch aus deiner Perspektive sehen. Ich finde, es ist wichtig, bei solchen Geschichten auch immer beide Perspektiven zu werden. Deswegen, bevor ich jetzt lache, möchte ich auch gerne erst die andere Perspektive sehen, damit wir das gegenüberstehen können, einfach damit da Klarheit herrscht. Vielleicht den Namen nicht mehr. Finden wir raus. Wir haben genug findige Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer, die das rausfinden. Wir haben genug Detektive unter unseren Hörern. Aber da war ich, den ganzen Trip, wir waren glaube ich eine Woche lang in Tallinn oder sowas, war ich sauer auf mein Englisch und dachte mir, die halten mich alle auf deinem Gehirn. Grössten Deppen, weil ich habe das Gefühl gehabt, das deutsche Studium war nicht so geil und alle konnten besser Englisch sprechen. Generell waren sehr viele so Dänen und Skandinavier dabei und so, die konnten alle wahnsinnig gut Englisch sprechen und so und die waren dann immer so die Schambolzen, alle haben die geliebt und die waren einfach wahnsinnig cool und eloquent in ihrer Sprache. Ich war froh, wenn ich so über die Runden kam, mit so everyday colloquial shit. Und naja, es hat, sagen wir mal, so halb funktioniert. Und da war ich immer so, man ist ja in der Fremdsprache erstmal so ein bisschen dusseliger. Man ist ein bisschen dümmer. Das ist wie so ein anderes Betriebssystem, was ein bisschen schlechter funktioniert. Buggy. Es ist auch frustrierend, weil man will immer sagen, yes, excuse me, I'm way smarter than I look right now, but I just can't express my genius because I don't have the words, the correct words, but I'm way smarter, you know. I'm way smarter than that. If you think, wow, this guy is smart, think, no, this guy is really smart. Yeah. Like, always add like 20 IQ points on top of it. Yeah. I'm way smarter than you think. Und es ist auch nicht so, dass man mit Amerikanern oder Engländern gesprochen hat, die dann checken, ah, der spricht gerade in einer fremden Sprache, ich bin Muttersprachler, easy, sondern es waren ja Leute, die es auch als Second Sprache gesprochen haben. Und deswegen hat man auch diesen Vorschuss nicht mehr. Heißt, Riesenschitshow, am Ende bin ich in Situationen gelandet, in denen ich nicht wollte, bin mit Leuten abends weg irgendwo hingegangen, wo ich gar nicht hin wollte. Egal, aber seitdem habe ich dann... Weil du einfach immer Yes und No verwechselt hast, dass bei dir die Grundlagen waren da leider schon schwierig. Diese doppelte Verneinungsstruktur, die Satzstruktur, do you mind? Do you mind if I don't shower right now? Jesus fucking hell. No, yes, I do not mind. One second, und dann schreibe ich es mir auf. Habe ich immer so einen Blog gehabt und habe dann immer so Plus und Minus daneben geschrieben. Das kürzt sich raus. Einfach diese vierfache Verneinung. Das kürzt sich raus. Yes. Yes, I don't mind. Ja. Das war eigentlich sehr lustig. Aber das stimmt. Man hat erst, manchmal sagt man erst Dinge und dann denkt man darüber nach und dann entwickelt man die Meinung dementsprechend, was man gesagt hat. Ja, deswegen, ich hätte auch nie Bock, irgendwie in Talkshows aufzutauchen oder so, weil du kannst ja, wenn du gefragt wirst, nicht einfach mal, hm, naja, ja, stimmt, wenn die zusammen koalieren würden, dann wäre der, ja. Uff, da haben Sie recht. Ja. So habe ich es noch gar nicht betrachtet. Jetzt noch gar nicht. Können wir Werbung machen, vielleicht kurz? Nee, wir sind bei Anne Will. Ach so. Deswegen haben wir keine Werbung. Ach so. Dann geben Sie mir kurz, können sich kurz alle umdrehen, ich muss kurz was aufschreiben, können sich kurz, tschuldigung, auch das Publikum, tschuldigung, können sich kurz alle umdrehen, ich muss kurz drüber nachdenken, über meine Antwort, danke. Klar, wir drehen uns kurz um. Hey, psst, hey, wer ist der Minister, wovon ihm spricht der? Wieso? Wer ist das, wovon wem spricht der die ganze Zeit? Ach so, der spricht von der Bundeskanzlerin. Ach so, okay. Was sagst du? Ist das gut oder schlecht? Welche Partei bin ich nochmal? FDP. FDP? Ja. Fuck! Ja, hab ich dir vorhin vorhin reingesagt. Deswegen guckst du mich so böse an. Ja, ich bin natürlich dein Feind, ich bin dein Rivale. Ich hab dir vor 20 Jahren schon gesagt, dass FDP keine gute Idee ist. Ich will bei euch mitspielen. Kann ich bei euch mitspielen?
Ja, aber nicht, können Sie jetzt?
Kann ich doch, ich will jetzt, kann ich jetzt bei euch mitspielen?
Können wir die Bauchbinde anbieten?
Nein.
Wir können doch aus dem F ganz locker ein P machen.
Pdp ist doch kein Problem.
Hey, hey, hey, mach P, Pdp.
Wofür soll das stehen?
Party, weiß ich nicht, die Party-Deutsche Partei. Keine Ahnung, Mann. Die Partiell-Demokratische Partei. Ja, genau. Partially. So, jetzt haben wir hier den Flotin Will von der Partiell-Demokratischen Partei sitzen. Genau, Entschuldigung für diese kurze Unterbrechung, aber ich finde, gute Antworten sollten auch eine gewisse Nachdenkzeit voran... Kann ich den Satz nochmal... Es ist schwierig, es ist schwierig, weil tatsächlich, du musst dir was sagen, jetzt glaube ich, kam noch nie in einer Talkshow vor, dass jemand gesagt hat, pfff, da haben sie mich jetzt... Keine Ahnung, da haben sie mich auf den falschen Fuss erwischt, auch dieses ganze Internet-Ding, wo immer entweder Daumen hoch, Daumen runter, wütende Emoji, lachende Emoji, wavy hand. Ich will das, keine Meinung. Ist es mir leicht egal. Ja, k.m. Weil auch bei Instagram, du kannst so auf Herz drücken und lässt das Herz weg. Herz weglassen ist auf so eine Art von, ist auch nicht, ist mir egal, das eher eine, gefällt mir nicht. So, und da denke ich mir, da fehlt halt die Mitte, so dieses. Ja, ich habe auch manchmal das Problem, ich will mir was merken, aber ich will es nicht gut finden. Du kannst es einfach auf die Merktaste drücken. Ja, aber das finde ich immer nicht, das finde ich immer nicht. Und dann weiß ich immer nicht, verdient es ein Herz, weil es ist halt jetzt, sage ich mal, ja was heißt verfassungsfeindlich, aber es ist halt so, ich würde es mir halt gern in der Hinterhand halten, im Sinne von Recherche für mein Buch und deswegen speichern, aber halt nicht gut finden. Hast du schon Titel für dein Buch? Ja. Möchtest du das sagen? Leute, lest das Buch, das ist echt ganz gut. Gutes Buch. Gutes Buch. Kann man mal, wird ganz gern genommen. Gutes Geschenk. Gutes Geschenk für interessierte junge Leute zwischen 21 und 39. Gutes Geschenk, wo man halt auch ein Buch schenkt, das man nicht so gerne mag, dass man denen was Richtiges schenkt, sondern halt so ein Mitbringselbuch. Das Buch heißt Wow, ein Buch, Dankeschön! Sodass derjenige, der es geschenkt bekommt, direkt den Titel vorlesen kann. Wow, oh, ein Buch, Dankeschön, ich lese gerne. Ja, ich lese ja gern, das habe ich noch nicht. Genau. Nachfolger, das habe ich schon.
Wow, danke für das Buch, das habe ich schon.
Umtausch ausgeschlossen.
Das ist Buch Teil drei. Teil drei ist Umtausch ausgeschlossen.
Ja, das ist eigentlich der beste Buchtitel. Kein Umtausch. No Refund.
No Refund.
Ah ja, finde ich nicht schlecht. Aber kannst du dir das vorstellen, so ein Buch schreiben, so ein witziges Anekdotenbuch aus dem Alltag oder wirklich so ein Hardcore-Science-Fiction-Buch? Du bist eine der erfolgreichsten Autoren Deutschlands. Du musst doch schon oft damit konfrontiert sein, dass Leute gesagt haben, hier, wir haben ein Buch geschrieben über so Zwerge im Bergwerk. Wir würden gerne deinen Namen drauf klatschen. Das Angebot habe ich schon häufig bekommen, das war schon häufig bekommen, das war den Eingangs, nee, das habe ich noch nicht bekommen. Na klar, die Leute assoziieren mit Stefan Tietze geschmackvolle humoristische Anekdoten und Texte. Wir würden gerne ihren Namen einfach auf das Buch drauf klatschen. Kleben. Einfach den anderen Namen überkleben. Ja, weil geschrieben wurde es von Igor Sadnansky. Das ist ein extrem talentierter Autor, aber der hat halt noch nicht den Namen und der ist ein Science-Fiction-Fantasy-Western-Autor und deswegen würden wir gerne einfach ihren Namen einfach wie so einen nassen Lachs einfach da drauf draufklatschen. Ja, wirklich so eine Briefmarke, die man zu viel angeleckt hat, so eine nasse, durchnässt, so drauf draufklatschen. Hätten Sie da Interesse, Herr Ties? Wenn diese konkrete Anfrage kommen würde, wäre ich intrigue, ja zu sagen. Do you mind if we put your name? Und ich sage, kein, ich weiß nicht. Würde es Sie stören, wenn wir nicht Ihren Namen nicht verwenden würden. Oh, nein,
mein alter Fein. Nein, die doppelte Verneinung.
Wurde ich noch nicht gefragt, nein.
Ich wollte schon mal gefragt, ob ich ein Buch schreiben möchte
und sage immer, dass ich mir das nicht zutraue.
Ja.
Ich habe da großen Respekt
einfach vor dieser Kunstform.
Aber irgendwann vielleicht habe ich diesen Respekt nicht mehr.
Ich habe nicht mehr Talent dann,
wenn ich es nicht, brauche ich nicht denken, oh, jetzt glaubt er, er hat es drauf. Nein, dann habe ich nur ein bisschen mehr Respekt vor der Artform Kunst. Oder ein bisschen mehr Geld angeboten bekommen. Also eins von beiden kann sein. Ich finde es ja schau nicht, wie es Autoren schaffen, wirklich so eine Idee durch so ein ganzes Buch zu ziehen. Ich bin auch so sprunghaft dafür.
Und nicht einfach dann zu sagen, oh, apropos, apropos Berge, wusstet ihr, dass viele Lifte jetzt umgebaut werden und Tiere in die Wipfel gebracht werden sollen. Also sozusagen, dass man sagt, Skilifte funktionieren nicht mehr, weil die Leute keinen Ski mehr fahren wollen, weil es keinen Schnee mehr gibt und die sich zu fein sind, da runterzukratzen auf so einer Steinpiste. Ich spule nochmal zurück, was war das denn gerade? Audible zurückspulen? Weil die sich zu fein sind, auf einer Steinpiste runterzufahren. Und deswegen haben die jetzt gesagt, was machen wir jetzt mit diesen ganzen Skiliften?
Und da setzen die jetzt Tiere rein.
Die setzen unten an der Talstation Tiere rein, Rehe, Bären, Bären, hier, Dings, wer ist denn die kleinen, warte mal, die Kleinen mit den Zähnen,
Freddy,
irgend so was Kleines, so ein kleines Krabbelzeug,
damit die eben sozusagen das neue Bevölkerung bevölkern. Aus den Skigebieten wurde über lange Zeit die Tiere rausgetrieben von den schwarzen Pisten. Genau so wird es mir auch gehen, weil du hast doch kein, du hast doch irgendwann bei 500 Seiten denkst du doch, das reicht mir jetzt mal das Thema. Ja. Und it may come as a surprise to you, liebe Podcast-HörerInnen,
aber ich bin sprunghaft.
Ja, ja.
Als 500-Seiten-Commitment auf ein fucking Thema.
Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen ...
Auf heisere Hummeln.
Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen Workout.
So wie Joggen oder so.
Du rennst los, du joggst, du bist völlig fertig, außer Atem,
denkst dir, das war eine gute Runde, schaust auf die Uhr, du joggst seit vier Minuten.
Und ich glaube, genau so ist es beim Buchschreiben auch so. Du schreibst und wow, geile Handlung, tolle Geschichte, toller Spruch und das waren jetzt zweieinhalb Seiten. Vor allem, das ist das eine und das andere ist dann so, selbst in Mails denke ich mir, dann habe ich das in den Mail geschrieben, lese ich nochmal durch und denke mir, das macht gar keinen Sinn.
Erstens, kann man das überhaupt so sagen und dann google ich diese Satzkonstruktion irgendwie. Aber dann, glaube ich, gibt es ja wiederum Lektorat, also Leute, die dann das auch wirklich durchlesen nochmal. Und dann weiß ich nicht, was deren Aufgabe ist. So irgendwie sagen die auch dann das Wort Metapher, haben sie viel zu häufig benutzt. Wie sieht die Arbeit eines Lektorats aus, einer Lektorin eines Lektorats? Ich glaube, die streichen halt so, Herr Dietze, Sie haben ja einmal komplett, Sie haben ja erst mal erzählt, welche Werbung Werbespots sie gerade gut finden. Ich glaube, das braucht es gar nicht für die Geschichte, weil sie erzählen ja so eine Romanze auf so einem Kreuzfahrtschiff. Ja, im All. Auf dem Kreuzfahrtraumschiff. Kreuzfahrtraumschiff. Und sie erst mal sagen, sie schreiben sie darüber, wie gern sie Star Wars mögen, dass sie ein bisschen enttäuscht waren von Star Wars. Genau, damit man weiss, woher ich komme. Genau, aber ich glaube, das braucht es gar nicht. Und dann, das Problem ist, die Figuren unterhalten sich quasi auch ausschliesslich über Star Wars. Und diese eine Figur hier, Baloni, erzählt den Gesamtplot von Star Wars Episode Fünftnacht, über 160 Seiten. Ich glaube, die Leute haben den Film gesehen. Ich glaube, das kann auch raus. Das Problem ist halt, wenn man sämtliche Star-Wars-Inhalte rausstreicht, bleiben halt noch neun Seiten. Und davon sind vier Register. Und ich habe Ihnen am Anfang schon gesagt, Romane haben in der Regel keine Register, das ist nicht nötig. Ich wollte alle Register ziehen. Okay. Sie schreiben das jetzt, Herr Titzel, Sie schreiben das jetzt nochmal und Sie strengen sich bitte ein bisschen mehr an. Ja, macht das ein Lektor. Ich glaube ja. Ich glaube ja. Beim Joggingexample waren, Beispiel kann man aber sagen, ist das so ein Trainertyp. Ich glaube ja. Der dann sagt, ach come on. Die Treppe hoch und runter. Was ist denn das für eine Metapher? Sie liebte ihn, wie er Ferrero Küsschen liebt? Das ist doch kein, das ist doch nicht romantisch. Wieso? Klar ist es romantisch. Das ist doch seine Lieblingssüßigkeit. Und die Liebe zu ihr war wie die Nuss im Haffaello? Ihnen ist nicht mal der Name eingefallen. Aber ist das so, dass die einem sagen, so jetzt nächste Seite, nächste Seite, komm, komm, eine Seite noch, drei, zwei, eins, noch fünf Wörter. Deadline, Deadline, nein, Deadline. Ich glaube schon. Ich glaube, viele Lektoren, die gerade jetzt leicht aufschmunzeln, werden sie gerade Grammatikfehler im neuen Fähnen- und von Schirach-Roman anschreiben. Ich glaube, die können leicht aufschmunzeln gerade, weil denen das sehr bekannt vorkommt, was wir gerade geschildert haben. Es sind nicht nur Grammatik-Nazis. Auch, doch, glaube ich auch, aber auch viel, das kann man so nicht sagen, das ergibt so keinen Sinn, das ist, hier fehlen Verben, hier fehlen Substantive, es sind 16 Mal der Buchstabe P hintereinander, was war da los? Nee, ich brauche halt jemanden, der mir sagt, nee, das Semikolon da war richtig. Ja, genau, auch positive Messages. Ja, oder das war falsch, meinetwegen auch. Aber eigentlich brauche ich jemanden, der mir sagt, was ein Semikolon ist. Im Grunde ja. Mein alter Latein hat immer gesagt, das kommt vor einem Den. Und weiter bin ich noch nicht gekommen mit meinem Semikolon-Recherchen, aber ich benutze es häufig vor Dens, benutze ich dann einen, aber man fängt selten einen Satz an mit den.
Mein Lateinlehrer hat immer gesagt, Latein ist eine tote Sprache.
Die with it.
Aber warum ist er nicht mehr Stimme runtergegangen?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe die Hälfte nicht verstanden.
Der Lateinler hat immer gesagt, Latein ist wie eine tote Sprache.
Ja, der war weird, der hat immer, wie ich so gesagt habe, wisst ihr, Latein ist zwar vielleicht eine tote Sprache.
So, wir machen weiter auf Seite 30. Also ganz merkwürdiger Typ.
Ja, wir beenden dann jetzt den Unterricht und alle blieben sitzen. Ja genau, es ging irgendwie nicht weiter. Ja, euch dann erstmal schöne Sommerferien. Also du hast in deiner Schulaufgabe eine Sechs geschrieben. Okay, nervig, sorry. Der ganzen Welt. Latein ist eine tolle Sprache. Und alle haben die Hoffnung, dass es nicht ist. Nichts kommt. Nee, er war verwirrend, war super verwirrend, aber der hat sich auch totgedacht über den Scheiss, den wir zusammen übersetzt haben. Das ist, glaube ich, schon echt erfüllend als Lateinlehrer. Da gibt es bestimmt ein Buch da draußen, der irgendwie liegt neben deinen, wo irgendwie mit einem offensichtlichen Adding noch auf jedes Buch dein Name drauf gekritzelt wurde. Falsch geschrieben, liegt auch so ein Buch von einem Lateinlehrer, der die lustigsten Herkules, Ars, den, Ars, die, irgendwas. Der Bello Finito, der Hund ist tot. Ja, sowas. Der Hund ist tot. Ah, okay. Wahrscheinlich heißt das Buch als Bello Finito. Ja, das kann gut sein. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube, es ist wahnsinnig lustig, was Lateinlehrer immer so erleben. Und das ist doch, glaube ich, weil man fragt sich immer, warum Lateinlehrer werden. Warum? Niemand mag das, die Sprache ist tot. Und trotzdem machen Leute weiter und werden Lateinlehrer und ich glaube, es liegt allein daran, weil das ist total rewarding, einfach dann mit so Schülern zu arbeiten, Schülerinnen, die keinen Bock haben und die sich Übersetzungen klauen, also Übersetzungen von alten Prüfungen nehmen und man nimmt dann diese alte Lateinlehrertrick, dass man in der Mitte mal einen Satz rausnimmt und die übersetzten Satz, der gar nicht da ist, aus der alten Übersetzung, finde ich nur noch die besten Sachen. Grossartig, grossartig. Bei uns, aber gab es tatsächlich bei uns auch, der Fünfer-Schüler, Sechster-Schüler, nie Hausaufgaben gemacht, hat perfekt die Schulaufgabe übersetzt, sogar der fehlende Satz. Ein fehlender Satz. Grossartig.
Interessant, dass sie sogar den Satz übersetzt haben, der gefehlt hat.
Naja, also ich liebe halt Katull und ich lese
die Texte auch privat und dann muss das
wahrscheinlich so reingerutscht sein.
Das wäre auch super lustig.
Ja genau, aber wie will man das nachweisen?
Vielleicht kannte er den Text schon.
Ja, kann sein. Du musst ihn ja beim
Schummeln erwischen. Ich glaube, Latein ist dafür da, dass Schüler Schummeln lernen. Also das ist ja ein wichtiger Skill in seinem Leben, weil niemand hat den Anspruch, tatsächlich Latein zu lernen, sondern du lernst halt, wie du dich durchwieselst mit möglichst wenig Aufwand, was tatsächlich die beste Lektion ist, die man in der Schule lernen kann. Ich glaube, man lernt in der Schule mehr durch Lernverweigerungen, als man tatsächlich lernt. Weil was machst du denn in deiner Arbeit? Du versuchst mit möglichst wenig Aufwand, dich irgendwie zum Feierabend zu kennen. Zum Wochenende retten. Ja, und das ist die Fähigkeit, die du eins zu eins in der Schule lernst. Die Zeit strecken, möglichst nicht dumm auszusehen und mit möglichst wenig Vorbereitung eine vier Minus noch irgendwie hinzukriegen. Und so ist das Leben noch. Es ist perfekt. Ist das Leben eine Vier-Minus? Das perfekte Leben ist eine Vier-Minus, glaube ich. Das ist ein guter Buchtitel. Ja. Das perfekte Leben ist eine Vier-Minus. Versetzungsgefährdet, wie ich gerade so in das nächste Lebensjahr komme. Florentin Will, des Titels. Also es steht dann auch noch mal als Autor, aber es ist auch schon Teil des Titels auch noch. Das finde ich auch lustig, wenn der Name auf meinem Buch falsch geschrieben wäre. Das finde ich, glaube ich, lustig. Ja, glaube ich auch. Kann man das nicht absichtlich auch machen? Steffner Tietze. Steffner Tietze. Steffner Tietze. Ja, warum nicht? Also da müsste man natürlich auch mit dem Buchtitel irgendwie einzahlen, irgendwie sowas. Nobody's Perfect. Steffner Tietze. Von Steffner Tietze oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Fehler sind das Gewürz in der Suppe des Lebens. Ja, Fehler gehören dazu. Fehler gehören zum Leben dazu. Steffner Tietze. Ja, das nicht schlecht. Okay. Ja, guck mal. Die 250 Seiten Inhalt brauchen wir noch. Aber das als Reklam, aber als Reklam-Buch. Oh ja, das finde ich nicht schlecht. Das finde ich mega geil. Bringt Reklam noch neue Bücher raus? Und wenn ja, wer ist dieses Knallharto-Komitee, was da dahinter sitzt und sagt, das ist jetzt Reklam würdig? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Das ist so gut wie Goethe, Schiller, Richard Wagner und Stefan Titzner. Wer sitzt da? Wer ist das Reklamgremium? Kann ich denn dafür sorgen, dass mein Reklambuch leuchten würde im Dunkeln? Dass dieses grelle Gelb auch im Dunkeln noch leuchtet? Ja. Ich meine, wir haben seit Jahrhunderten die Technologie, um Dinge im Dunkeln leuchten zu lassen. Warum benutzen wir das nicht ständig? Ich glaube, wir mögen auch, dass es dunkel ist hier und da. Ja, und vor allem, ich glaube, das ist auch krebserregend. Ich habe mir letztens eingefallen, dass ich meine gesamte Jugend unter diesen Sternen gelegen habe. Ich hatte ein Hochbett, das sehr hoch war. Zu hoch. Manche sagen zu hoch. Es war eigentlich ein zu hoch Bett. Und was
dazu geführt hat, dass ich wirklich wenige
Zentimeter unter der Decke gelegen habe.
Manchmal im Albtraum so aufgeschreckt böse und dann so...
Ich bin also
extra lange Leiter hochgeklettert,
um dann wie in einem Sarg
wirklich zu liegen, mit quasi
keinem Raum. Und dann an der
Decke waren direkt diese Sterne befestigt,
die in der Nacht leuchten.
Das heißt, diese Krebsgeriegel...
Diese ein Zentimeter Karenz,
die noch da waren, die noch mal
irgendwie diese Uransterne,
die noch mal direkt in meine Augen
geleucht haben. Und wer Simpsons oder generell als Comics guckt,
weiss, dass diese Farbe nicht
gesund ist. Nee, du wirst
von Kind auf erzogen,
dass du von dieser Farbe
fluchtartig davonlaufen sollst. Deswegen glaube ich,
bin ich einfach verstrahlt, verseucht,
seit Nee, du wirst von Kind auf erzogen, dass du von dieser Farbe fluchtartig davonlaufen sollst. Deswegen glaube ich, bin ich einfach verstrahlt, verseucht seit Anfang an, alle auf Kopfhöhe. Aber ich fand das tatsächlich ganz gut. Ich mag dieses Gefühl, so ganz eingedeckt zu sein und so komplett eingehöhlt zu sein. Ich glaube, eingemummelt. Ich glaube, das kommt noch aus der Mummelzeit der Menschen, wo sie noch in Höhlen gelebt haben, wo einfach dieses Gefühl der Geborgenheit durch Enge auch einfach entstanden ist. Oh, ich habe das Gegenteil. Ich liebe offene, grosse Säle, in denen ich schlafe. Deswegen schlafe ich häufig im Westflügel, weil da ist meistens... Der ist ja der grössere, nicht grössere, aber höherer. Der höhere, der deutlich höhere. Und deswegen schlafe ich am liebsten.
Ja, finde ich auch gut.
Da ist die Decke schön hoch. Draußen schlafen? Da ist mir zu viel los. Da ist wieder zu hoch. Das Hüttenzfirmament ist dir zu hoch. Da ist mir zu viel los auch. Nee, eigentlich finde ich es total toll. Würde ich gerne mal machen, eigentlich so eine Zelttour mit so einem Bulli los, so einem Zelt los und dann vielleicht mal irgendwo einfach an so eine Steilküste einfach mal rausschlafen legen.
Ich glaube eh, dass die ASMR-atmosphärische Soundrevolution noch aussteht. Es gibt ja so Regen und Feuer und alles das und dann gibt es so verschiedene Apps und sowas. Ich glaube, was richtig gut ankommen würde, Achtung, jetzt mal ganz kurz an die ganzen NFT-Freaks da draußen oder Investment-Whatever, Leute, bitte klaut die Idee nicht, weil ich glaube, die ist richtig viel Geld wert. Und zwar, pass auf, du liegst in deinem Bett, Bettchen, Kopfhörer auf, ja, aber die sind connected, und zwar sind die connected beim Gehirn, Nein, die sind connected zu einem Mikrofon,
das irgendwo im Wald steht und das eins zu eins
die Geräusche des Waldes, sei es
Regen, sei es Wind,
an dich überträgt. Aber ist nicht nach
Minute eins halt so ein
Specht am Mikro?
Das ist natürlich worst case.
Oder best case. Du willst ja auch
Specht am Mikro.
Weil ich glaube, diese Romantik, von wegen man liegt jetzt gerade im Wald. Okay, gut, da müssen wir vielleicht dann diverse Selbstschussanlagen aktivieren, sodass dieses Geklacker BAM einmal kurz beendet wird. Du legst dich ins Bett und dann hast du so. BAM! Also ich glaube, das ist eine geile Idee, weil ich glaube, diese Romantik von im Wald liegen und Regen prasselt auf die Zeltdecke und so ist geil, aber ich glaube, du musst es live haben. Du musst es live haben, du kannst dir noch richtig vorstellen, wie es ist, gerade im Wald zu sein, da ist ein richtig gutes Mikrofon. Und dann ist er der nächste Schritt, Leute werden ja versuchen, dieses Mikrofon zu finden und mit einer Tröte durch den Wald zu laufen, um irgendwann zu hören, komme ich näher gerade oder nicht. Das heißt, du hast gleichzeitig ... Wenn der V01 ist ... Du hast einerseits diese Romantik der Stille und Verlorenheit im Wald, andererseits weißt du, es ist endlich. Genau, du hast ein Geocaching-Abenteuer und du weißt, es ist endlich, weil du weißt, noch wurde ich nicht gefunden, noch liege ich in meinem Wald und bin versteckt. Aber sie sind auf der Suche nach mir und ich höre sie kommen, sie kommen immer näher und sie kommen immer näher und habe ich noch eine Nacht oder nicht. Ich glaube, das ist ein richtig spannendes Abenteuer. Oh, Live-Atmo finde ich das richtig super. So Live-ASMR.
Weil der Trend geht ja zu sowas.
Neulich war ich bei
Gruselig bei Reddit unterwegs
und da gibt es ein Subreddit, ich weiß nicht, wie der heisst,
das wird glaube ich gut, dass ich es nicht mehr weiss, wo
Live-Kamera-Streams,
die offen zudemlich sind,
oh ja,
halt gesammelt werden und da kannst du draufklicken und dann
hast du so ein random Bürogebäude
in Pittsburgh,
meinetwegen, und dann ist da so eine Fabrik
Vielen Dank. Oh ja. Halt gesammelt werden und da kannst du draufklicken und dann hast du so ein random Bürogebäude in Pittsburgh, meinetwegen, und dann ist da so eine Fabrik und so oder so eine grosse offene Bürofläche mit so diesen Cubicles und oben hast du eine Kamera. Und aus irgendeinem Grund hat man die nicht verschlüsselt oder sowas und lädt einfach live Bilder hoch und du kannst die Leute beim Arbeiten zugucken, die das nicht wissen. Wahnsinn. Und dann habe ich es auch ein paar Mal gerne geguckt. Irgendwie fand ich es irgendwie super weird. Das hat natürlich auch so einen illegalen Aspekt, der irgendwie auch aufregend ist. Auf der anderen Seite ist man aber auch, glaube ich, einfach, und das passt ja auch zu seiner Idee, man ist als Mensch gern woanders. Ja. Man ist einfach nicht gern da, wo man ist. Man will die Atmung von woanders. Ja, der Mensch. Man will Livebilder von woanders. Der Mensch ist an dieses Fleischgefängnis-Körper gebunden und an Raum und Zeit gebunden. Und ich glaube, Raumreisen sind vielleicht noch besser als Zeitreisen. Jederzeit überall sein zu können, fliegen zu können, nicht gebunden zu sein von der schneckenhaften Geschwindigkeit, mit der wir Menschen übers Land krebsen, sondern überall sein zu können. Ich glaube, das ist ein Wunsch, den man den Leuten erfüllen kann. Es gibt auch so eine tolle App, wo man zum Einschlafen sich so eine Mittelalter-Kulisse bauen kann. Also dann hast du so Regler und kannst dann einzeln das nervige Pferd oder die nervige Strassenmusik ausmachen. Und dann gibt es einen Bettler und dann kannst du aber auch sagen, nee, der soll kein Geld dir ans Set bekommen, was klimpert. Da kannst du das Geld ausmachen. Und dann hat man aber immer das Bild von diesem Bettler im Kopf, der aber kein Geld mehr bekommt. Oh Gott. Nee, aber das ist sehr detailreich. Ja, das klingt echt entspannt. Detailreich kannst du dir quasi deine Welt zusammenbauen, das ist eigentlich ganz cool. Ich meine, wir haben ja Mikrofone, kann ich mir dein Mikrofon mal ausleihen für eine Woche? Willst du es einfach in den Wald bringen? Ich sag dir nicht, wohin ich es bringen. In den Wald. Du willst es in den Wald stellen. Wie kann man Geld verdienen damit? Erstmal, glaube ich, ich musste sehr viele Mikrofone kaufen. Da sehe ich schon erstmal kein Geld. Und dann brauche ich einen Satelliten, oder was? Du brauchst einen Router und dann erstmal eine Verlängerungsgabel. Ja, stimmt, die Stromversorgung, da brauche ich dann so ein Solar-Ding. So einen Dieselgenerator. Und dann schön Interface, Mikro, Router. Ja. So, dann machst du das alles schnellst. Ich glaube, ich mache das wirklich. Ich glaube, das wird mein Winterprojekt. Ich mache das und lade das auf einer Website hoch, Homepage. Und dann schauen wir mal, wer... Und dann ist da auch Gold versteckt. Und dann schauen wir mal, wer das als erstes findet. Ja, Gold. Gold Barren. Ein Stück Gold. Stück Gold. Stück Gold. So ein Stein. Ja, und dann ist es die Microphone Gold Hunt Show. Microfound. Ja, Lost and Microfound. Gold, Icy Gold. Ellie Golding. Okay, alles klar. Sponsored by Ellie Golding, I gold you so. Alles klar.
Dann.
Nee, aber das finde ich in Ellie eine sehr gute Idee.
Also ich würde es mir auf jeden Fall anhören zum Schlafen.
Gab es nicht mal so eine App, so eine hörartige App, wo man mit fremden Menschen reden kann nachts?
Ich will das wie ein Chatroulette haben, nur mit nur Sprache und random Menschen aus der Welt.
Oh Gott, ich habe keine Ahnung. Das ist unglaublich gruselig. Du kannst einfach random Telefonnummern anrufen. Das kannst du auch machen. Ich will ja, dass die auch im Bett liegen und schlafen wollen. Aber die App heisst Sleepover. Und eine Regel gibt es, sonst wird sie sofort gebannt, auf Lebenszeit flüstern. Ja. Hey, hey, Scheife. Ja, wer bist du? Ich bin wach diese wir haben uns ja gerade erst verbunden wer bist du denn ich bin babino okay ich bin der stefan ja kannst du bitte leise sein ich würde Ich würde gerne versuchen einzulassen. Was hast du heute so du heute so erlebt? Ich habe einen Cappuccino getrunken. Boah, mir war so aufregend heute. So viel passiert. Der Ben war. Und wenn die App Schnarchen detected, wird sofort wegeskippt und es kommt der nächste rein. Ach krass. Das heißt, es ist ja Ken Schlaf, oder wie? Nicht Schnarchen. Und wenn du es laut sprichst, also wenn du es mal so machst, dann wirst du auch direkt rausgekegelt.
Ah ja, okay, weil das gröste Problem ist, die Leute schreien dann, um die Leute zu erschrecken.
Genau, das darf nicht vorgehen.
Ja, das darf halt bei mir auch nicht passieren, dass sich irgendein Sträuch anschleicht und dann ganz laut ins Mikrofon schreit.
Genau. Und was auch gruselig ist, Massenmörder. Aber das ist ja generell ein Problem.
Aber bei der App werden die nicht so lange atmen und denken, I kill you, I kill you. Das wäre auch nicht so schön, wenn du halt schlafen willst und plötzlich bist du hellwach, weil Charles Manson dir ins Ohr flüstert. Ja, die meisten Ideen werden dadurch schlecht, dass Menschen schlecht sind. Du hast eine coole Idee und sagst, ah scheiße, ich habe kurz vergessen, dass Menschen einfach das schlimmste sind, was es gibt. Schade. Ja, und das ist wirklich gar keine doofe Erkenntnis. Ich will mit einem Eisbären reden, nicht mit einem Menschen. Ich will mit einem Frettchen, ich will mit einem Zoo irgendeinem Pfau zugeschaltet sein und mit dem Pfau reden. Und der Pfau sagt, ja, ja, ja, du hast echt ein hartes Leben, aber ich bin halt auch eingesperrt einfach, komme ja einfach nicht raus. Nee, Moment, Pfau, du bist das einzige Tier nicht eingesperrt. Ja, du hast echt ein hartes Leben, aber ich bin halt auch eingesperrt, komme ja einfach nicht raus. Moment, Pfau, du bist das Einzige, das ist hier nicht eingesperrt. Ja, das stimmt. Dich sich auf den Wegen rumlaufen. Ja, aber sag das nicht weiter, sag das niemandem weiter. Du läufst auf den Wegen rum und wenn man dir zu nah kommt, dann machst du dein Feder-Dings. Ja. Federrat. Ich habe jetzt eine komplett neue Federbefiederung jetzt hier. Willst du mal sehen? Alles komplett neu.
Nee, danke.
Weißt du, dass du das Logo bist von NBC, dem Sender?
Was?
Ich oder was?
Ja, also eines von deinen Tierenartfreunden.
Ja, da habe ich keinen Cent gesehen.
Hast du keinen Cent gesehen? Keinen Cent gesehen.
Null.
Gar nichts.
Schau mal, hier, das ist das Logo von NBC.
Das ist doch nicht ihr scheißernst, oder?
Ja, du musst deinen Anwalt anrufen.
Ich lasse mich einfach da hinfliegen, wenn ich fliegen könnte, mit meinen tausend Federn. Fucking Bullshit, Pfauen können fliegen. Nein, Pfauen können nicht fliegen. Pfauen können mit Sicherheit fliegen mit den Federn. Die können gleiten, ich glaube, die können gleiten. Ich glaube, wenn so ein Marilyn Monroe-artiger Windstoss von unten kommt, können die kurz abheben. Wo war die eigentlich immer unterwegs, frage ich mich. Naja, in den U-Bahn-Schachten. Ah ja. Haben wir auch gesehen. Ah ja. Haben wir auch gesehen in New York. Da ist auch dein Röckchen beim Aukufloch. Ja, kann sein. Manchmal bin ich auch absichtlich drüber gelaufen, um ein bisschen Aufsehen zu erregen. Ja, das ist dir gel ja. Oh ja. Aber das kann sein. Ich meine, Pauen können fliegen. Nein, Pauen können nicht fliegen. Warum würden die sonst nicht einfach wegfliegen? Weil denen die Federn gestutzt wurden. Nein. Wie bei vielen Tieren, die eigentlich fliegen konnten, aber dann wurden denen die Federn gestutzt, damit die nicht wegkommen. Hummer zum Beispiel konnten einfach so direkt aus dem Wasser heraus, wie so ein Reverse-Hecht, einfach so in die Luft fliegen. Gen den Himmel schießen. Gen den Himmel schießen. Nee, nee, nee. Aber haben sie nicht gemacht? Du meinst Raben oder was im London Tower? Nee. Denen auch die Flügel gestutzt werden, damit die nicht wegkommen? Ähnlich jetzt? Ja, ja. Nein. Ja, doch. Was? Doch, doch. Ist das allgemein? Kannst du alles im London Tower angucken? Meine Hoffnung ist, wenn ich dann diese random Security-Kameras, die ich jetzt nicht gucke mehr, Leute, aber dass ich da mal einen Mord entdecke drauf. Und dann weiß ich ja, wer es war. Mega, mega cooler. Eigentlich müsste man man es andersrum machen, eigentlich müsste man eine Kamera installieren, die dann da hochgeladen wird und die man ja laufen lassen, um dann da Hinweise zu streuen. So, dann liegt da irgendwo eine Leiche oder so, man sieht nur den Arm oder so, rechts oben, ganz klein. Und man guckt mal, wie lange es im Reddit dauert, bis jemand bemerkt, Leute, seit Tagen liegt da ein Arm. Und dann, nachdem das geschrieben
wird, ist der Arm weg. Und alle, lesen
die mit? Wissen die, was da los ist?
Und dann plötzlich taucht in einer anderen
Cam ein Bein
auf und sie sagen, hier ist ein Bein.
Und dann sagen die, und dann ist das
Bein weg und lesen die mit.
Dann hast du so eine richtige
Krimi-Geschichte und dann für drei Zuschauer. und dann findest du Gold, dann vergräbst du Gold. Gold, gern, ich weiß nicht genau, wie du auch die Idee hast. Und dann finden Leute Gold. Was wie Gold? Ja, das ist doch das Beste, was du finden kannst. Stell dir mal vor, es gibt so oft die Situation, dass ich irgendeine Schatulle oder eine Truhe oder ein Etui oder sowas öffne und dann bin ich immer enttäuscht vom Inhalt. Hast du schon mal eine Box geöffnet, wo du wirklich gesagt hast, geil, Mann, da sind richtig coole Sachen drin. Nee. Nee, ne? Eine Truhe, mal so eine richtige schwere Eisentruhe geöffnet. Nee, man ist auch irgendwie enttäuscht, wenn man dann so auf dem Dachboden der Eltern unterwegs ist und so und dann so große Sachen, so Truhe oder so einen Koffer, alten Koffer und dann macht man das auf und dann sind da alte Fliesen drin, damit man, falls mal eine Fliese kaputt geht, noch Ersatzfliesen. Ersatzfliesen ist basically alles am Dachboden. Oder denkst du, die Fliesen kenne ich schon mein Leben lang. Ja. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es davon noch mehr gibt. Das wertet die Fliesen ab, die ich schon kenne.
Ehrlich gesagt ja. Gut, ich wusste nicht, dass die von hinten so aussehen, aber wusste ich auch nicht, dass mir das interessiert. Ja. Tut's nicht. Ich glaube, ich habe mein Grösstes und so ein braves Kind war ich, dass das Schlimmste, was ich als Kind gemacht habe, ist, ich habe im Bart mit dem Pömpel gespielt und habe diesen Pömpel gegen die Wand gepömpelt, Speerwurf, glaube ich, kennt jeder das Spiel, schön einen an die Wand pömpeln. Und dann hast du eine Fliese abgepömpelt? Mit Anlauf und dann einfach schön an die Fliese und dann wollte ich den Pömpel abziehen und da kam die Fliese mit raus. Kam die Fliese mit raus. In Gänze oder in Teilen? In Gänze, voll und ganz erhalten. Und da habe ich richtig Panik bekommen, weil das war das Schlimmste, was ich gemacht habe als Kind.
So ein fucking langweiliges Kind einfach.
Nicht mal irgendwie was kaputt gemacht, nicht den Alkohol der Eltern getrunken, sondern einmal eine Fliese und dann so, ja, dann kann man wieder ankleben.
Und dann konnte man sich einfach wieder ankleben.
Dann konnte man relativ flott wieder ankleben, ja, im Handumdrehen.
Da musste man nicht mal in Speicher, in Dachboden und die Ersatzfliesen rausholen, weil die normalen Fliesen ausgereicht haben. Hat man dir den Pömpel danach weggenommen oder konntest du weiter unbeirrt mit dem Pömpel spielen? So wenig aufsehenerregend war dieser Akt, dass ich danach weiter pömpeln durfte. Also mir wurde nicht mal die Tatwaffe entzogen. Nicht mal die geringste Strafe der Tatwaffenentzug fand statt, sondern ich durfte weiter fröhlich damit hantieren.
Man hätte sogar dankbar sein können, dass du auf diese lose Fliese auf der Wand aufmerksam gemacht hast. Ich glaube, mein Vater hat sowas in der Richtung gesagt. Ich wollte mich jetzt ein bisschen rebellischer darstellen, als ich tatsächlich war. Aber ich glaube, meine Rebellenphase kommt noch. Ich glaube, meine Rebellionsphase kommt noch. Kommt noch? Ich komm noch. Ich werde wirklich was kaputt machen. Ich werde mit einem Fussball Blumenkästen kaputt schießen und ein Fenster kaputt machen. Und all das würde ich, glaube ich, noch kommen. Irgendwie so ein Böller bei der Schwester in die Haare oder irgendwie was, keine Ahnung. Sowas in der Richtung wird alles noch kommen. Ich glaube, das kommt viel zu spät. Ich weiß noch, dass ich mal, da habe ich am meisten Ärger bekommen als Kind, das Auto meines Vaters, da habe ich die Handbremse gelöst und es ist die Einfahrt runtergerollt durch die ganze Strasse in den Zaun der Nachbarn rein. Und er hat das gesehen, nee, stimmt, nee, das war das Auto meiner Mom, da ist es einfach in den Zaun der Nachbarn gerast. Und dann mein Vater hat das Gleiche gemacht, dass ich die Handbremse gelöst habe. Bei meiner Mom bin ich einfach draufgestiegen, das war so eine händische Handbremse. Mein Vater hatte so eine, die man so ziehen musste. Und da wollte ich das aus Versehen, das ist mir auch passiert einfach, bei der anderen bin ich einfach draufgetreten, da habe ich die aus Versehen gelöst, Auto ist runtergerollt, mein Vater hat es gesehen, ist dem Auto hinterhergerannt und der war auch wieder drauf und drin, in den gleichen Zaun zu fahren und die Nachbarn standen schon wieder, oh Gott. Der gleiche, der Zau, der genau frisch gestrichen ist, genau neu, genau da wird der Rengstatt. Und die Nachbarn standen schon dann, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein!
Und mein Vater ist aber im Moment wach gewesen, ist rumgerannt und hat das Auto aufgehalten, indem er reingestiegen ist und auf die Bremse getreten ist.
Wow.
So, und dabei ist nur der Blinkerhebel abgebrochen.
Und am nächsten Tag sind wir in die Ostsee gefahren, fünf Stunden schön an die Ostsee.
Und aber dieser, was man halt hat, um zu blinken, dieser Stab ist abgebrochen. Wie ist der abgebrochen? Durch seine Heldentat reinzusteigen und reinzuechten. So und dann am nächsten Tag müssen wir fünf Stunden an die Ostsee fahren, ohne Blinker schlecht. Und da ist ja auch alles mit Licht und so wird da geregelt und so. Der Scheibenbischer wird auch angemacht durch diesen Hebel. Da hat er aber, und seitdem denke ich, Autos sind irgendwie auch auf Sand gebaut, hat er nämlich, er hat dann so eine alte Silvesterrakete, die wir noch im Keller hatten, genommen, hat das Ende, hat diesen Stab abgeschnitten, weil das genau die richtige Größe hatte, hat es auf die richtige Länge geschnitten und hat diesen Stab, diesen Holzstab, da reingesteckt in das Loch. Ja. Und dann konnte er blinken. Genial. Aber dann dachte ich mir, so viel sind Autos, einfach Löcher mit... Im Grunde, ja. Es ist nur ein sophisticated Stock, aber basically sind überall Stöcke irgendwo reingesteckt, wenn man die richtig dreht und fliegt und so. Und man könnte diesen, dieseesterrakete nach oben, dann hat man nach rechts geblinkt, nach unten, nach links, dann konnte man so leicht drehen, dann hat man das Licht geblinkt. Genial. Aber als du gesagt hast, wir hatten im Kerl noch eine Silvesterrakete, dachte ich, er hat die ganze Fahrt zur Ostsee mit Silvesterraketen geblinkt, immer nur nach rechts abbiegen wolltet. Stefan, jetzt nach rechts! Und links blinke! Einfach jedes Mal. Und du hinten im Kofferraum mit dem ganzen Arm voller Silvesterraketen. Ja, ja, Papa, rechts! Wir fahren rückwärts! Mach die Wundergerd's Land! Ja! Ah, das wäre auch gut. Und du Einfach als Kanonier hinten komplett schwarz und alle Richtigen. Ah, das wäre auch gut. Nur einfach als Kanonier hinten komplett schwarz und alle Richtige.
Ah, das wäre schon cool.
Nee, so cool war es nicht.
Aber das war dann die Idee mit der Silvester-Raketen.
So würde man es dann in einem Film überhöhen.
So in einem Little-Messunshine-Film, alle Blinker ist kaputt, die Hupe ist kaputt,
wir müssen alles mit Silvester-Raketen.
Die auch aus Akt 1 kennen.
Nee, und da habe ich richtig Eier bekommen. Weil es war für alle Beteiligten eine Scheissituation. Vor allem für die Silvesterrakete, die ja jetzt auseinandergebrochen war. Ja, die man nicht mehr anmachen konnte. Wahnsinn. Nicht mehr angemacht. Wie denn, das hatte keinen Stab mehr. Ja, aber ich dachte Halbstab. Nee, das ist so ein ordentlich Stab. Bist man, also da unterschätzt man nicht diesen Blinkerhebel. Und ihr habt die dann nicht angemacht ohne Stab? Das ist doch das Beste, die ohne Stab anzumachen. Das habe ich mir nicht getraut. Du hast dann halt nicht die Stabilität, aber dafür die Unberechenbarkeit, die ein solches Krachererlebnis vielleicht sogar erst richtig spannend hat. Aber hier meine Frage, will man die? Ich schon. Oh, echt? Ich schon. Ich habe immer die abgemacht und dann so über die Straße fliegen lassen, die Silvester-Raketen, oder halt an Skateboard gebunden. Da denke ich immer, dass ich niemanden kenne, der an Silvester schon mal gestorben ist, ist ein absolutes Wunder. Verwunderlich, ja, absolut. Aber es gibt, glaube ich, sehr viele Unlücke an Silvester. Wir haben immer, das war immer der schönste Tag Silvester, und ich habe auch dann so einen alten Besenstiel, so einen metallisch hohlen Besenstiel benutzt und da die Böller reingetan und da hatte ich so ein Gewehr. Und das ist mir auch einmal voll in der Hand explodiert, einfach komplett aufgerissen unten, wo ich mir auch dachte, ja, jetzt einfach schön meine Hand verlieren könnte. Aber es ist auch einfach eine tolle Geschichte. Aber was war deine Reaktion, kurz Schock und dann auch Lachen. Geil! Und dann direkt abgeschnitten, zugehämmert und weitergemacht mit der Nächsten. Also das ging dann direkt Schlag auf Schlag. Wahnsinn. Ja? Ja, krank. Aber hat Spaß gemacht. Ja, ja, nee. Weil mich war dann der Depp, der auch dann immer schon zu 20 Tage vor Silvester angefangen hat zu Böllern, weil ich so viele Böller hatte, dass ich dann auch nicht immer warten wollte so lange und dann schon überlegen musste, wie ich es mache und dann an Papierflieger gebunden, die dann explodiert sind in der Luft und alles und die ganze Geschichte.
Sämtliche Schwarzpulver und Effektkübelchen, Knüllchen, alle zusammengekippt und immer in so ein Taschentuch, das zusammengebunden und Zündchen drangemacht.
Tischtennisbälle war bei uns immer das Projektilische Tischtennisball aufgemacht und dann fünf Wunderkerzen reingebröselt, Schwarzpulver rein und dann einfach unberechenbar. Again, was ist damit passiert? Ja, die sind einfach schön explodiert oder halt mit Wunderkerzen und halt so einem großen Flammenferno aufgegangen. Okay. Macht schon Spaß, macht schon Spaß, kann man nichts dagegen sagen. Ja.
Dieses Jahr Silvester mal so richtig wieder feiern, richtig mit Böllern und Rumballern.
Ich glaube wirklich, wenn ich auf so eine edlen Dinnerparty eingeladen werde, ich habe einfach schön die Bomben dabei, einfach die Böller dabei und einfach, ey geil, lass uns ein bisschen böllern.
Und dann haben so feine Setzgläser und so Ballkleider an und du bist auf der Straße um 12 Uhr und flippst komplett aus, weil du hast einen Medizinball mit Schwarzpulver. Cargopants, Rucksack, ich bin dabei, ich bin unterwegs mit meinen Jungs. Und so eine schwarze Skimaske auf, damit man dich nicht erkennt auf den Überwachungskameras. Ja. Wir haben auch immer den zugefrorenen See gesprengt. Da war dann der See komplett zugefroren und wir haben immer versucht, den aufzusprengen, weil einige Böller konnten auch unter Wasser brennen, was unfassbar ist bis heute. Ich nicht verstehe, wie das geht. Wenn du die angezündet hast und unter Wasser gesteckt hast, die sind nicht ausgegangen. Und dann haben wir dann so lange Stiele gebaut und haben dann so Sprengsätze dran gebaut. Aber allein der Versuch, könnte der Böller auch unter Wasser funktionieren, ist ja schon hirnrissig. Ja, aber es geht. Es geht. Ja, warum sollte man es probieren? Und dann haben wir versucht, das mit Stäben so ein Loch gemacht, am Rand vom See und dann so unter die Eisfläche geschoben, um es aufzusprengen. Rückblickend die armen fucking Fische, die einfach sich dachten, habt ihr eigentlich einen kompletten Schaden, es ist Mittag und ihr ballert hier einfach in unserem See rum. Keine Ahnung, ob Fische ein Gehör haben in der Hinsicht, oder denken können, Emotionen haben, wütend sein können, die wirklich zu Wut fähig sind. Letztens haben wir eine Doku gesehen über Shrimps, weil es ein Riesenproblem ist, dass Shrimps von Parasiten befallen sind. Und die haben unter ihrem Panzer so einen riesen Parasiten, also der wirklich so groß ist wie ihr Kopf, nahezu alle. Und es gibt so einen YouTuber, der zieht die immer raus, die Parasiten. Und dann hat der auch so nebenbei erwähnt, ja, Shrimps sind nicht fähig, Schmerz zu verspüren. Von daher ist es nicht so schlimm für die. Aber die werden halt zu sehr besteuert. Alles von ihrem Essen nimmt, wird halt ein Teil weggenommen von den Parasiten.
Ja, gar kein Schmerz. So, das ist gar nicht. Also ist es dann schon, ist es nicht besser, keinen Schmerz zu spüren? Woher weiss er das auch? Und Moment, und ist der Parasit so krass, dass die quasi wie so Facehugger diese Shrimps langsam übernehmen? Nee, ich glaube nicht. Die hängen sich nur dran.
Vor allem, das ist echt weird.
Bei der Parasit, das ist es gleichzeitig Weibchen und Männchen. Und das Weibchen ist riesengroß und das Männchen sitzt nur ganz klein so drauf, wie so eine Art Steuer, wie so ein Pilot, der auf diesem riesigen Weibchen drauf sitzt und die beiden sind da eingezogen in diesem Shrimp. Es ist eine furchtbare Welt. Die Tierwelt ist wirklich furchtbar, einfach schrecklich,
scheusslich, grausam. Wie viele Leute sitzen im Biologiestudium und denken
sich, sie machen jetzt irgendwie Häschen und Kaninchen
und dann, ja, Parasitenwurm schwimmt
dem ins Nasenloch rein, frisst das Gehirn
langsam auf und programmiert das Gehirn
um, um dann wieder einem anderen Tier in die Nase
zu schwimmen und denkst dir, ach,
ich bin hier raus, auf gar keinen Fall. widerlich, widerlich, widerlich, einfach rausgehen, einfach so, muss man so eine Kamera vor so ein Uni-Hörsaal stellen und die Leute, die einfach schadenweise rausgehen, und dann die ekelhaften Parasiten, die da im Auge wohnen, und Herren, ey. Aber wie heißt die Doku? Wie heißt die Doku? Ich bin da irgendwie ganz tief in so einer Ekel, es gibt ja so diese ganze Ekel-YouTube, wo so Pickel ausgedrückt werden. Und jetzt bin ich auch bei einem, der so Kuhhufe macht, der so Kuhhufe, wenn die dann sich irgendwie so Blasen eingetreten haben und dann so Schwellungen haben und der kratzt das alles aus und ich bin da gefangen, der Algorithmus, ich bin in Geiselhaft des Algorithmus, ich komme da nicht mehr raus, jetzt bin ich auch bei diesen Parasitenschrimp-Nummern und es ist furchtbar, ich bin in einem ganz ekelhaften YouTube gefangen, es ist die Hölle, es ist wirklich die Hölle für mich. Ich wünsche mir mal so ein Reset, so ein YouTube-Reset, weil ich komme da nicht mehr raus. Oh, das geht sehr einfach. Ja, das geht sehr, sehr einfach. Ganz nur ein Account machen. Das wäre mein größter Traum, mal wirklich so bei YouTube auf so einen Reset-Button zu drücken. Ich glaube, das wäre das schönste, wirklich, ich würde da hunderttausende Euro dafür bezahlen. Okay, ja, ich mache es dir. Das wäre das schönste, was es nur überhaupt gibt, wirklich. Ja, wenn du... Du würdest den grössten Gefallen tun aller Zeiten. Also sowas
kostet halt auch. Ja, gerne.
Jederzeit. Ich zahle dir jeden Preis.
Jeden Preis. Jeden Preis. Ich habe noch
zwei Goldbarren noch zu Hause.
Die hatte ich eigentlich geplant
für das Mikrofon-Event.
Mikrofon. Aber
kann ich dir auch geben.
Genau, das macht zwei Goldbarren.
Okay, gut. Ich habe genau zwei Goldbarren zu Hause. Ja, genau. Dann mache ich dir das Reset. Ja. Nee, das ist eine gute Idee, auf jeden Fall. Ich versuche teilweise, mittlerweile schaue ich nicht mehr YouTube-Videos, weil ich sie sehen will, sondern weil ich gegensteuern will. Ich versuche diesen riesigen Algorithmus-Dampfer, der gerade direkt auf den Wasserfall zufährt, in Ekel-YouTube hinein. Auf einen parasitären Ekel-Heiter-YouTube versuche ich gerade entgegenzusteuern, indem ich mir nur Häschenfell-Analyse und unser neuer Hundewelpen, um da einfach so entgegen, so Anti-Ekel, so in Süssheit reinzusteuern irgendwie. Und hier Puddingrezept und so, einfach um da wieder wegzukommen. Aber du darfst halt auch nicht übersteuern, sonst bist du da wieder. Es ist halt die Frage, wie der Algorithmus das liest, ob er jetzt denkt, ah, du magst süss und Ekel, hier hast du ein Häschen mit Parasiten, oder ob der eher denkt, ah, das ist das Gegenteil, mal gucken, wie lange er das Gegenteil will, dann nullt es sich. Ist halt die Frage, wir brauchen jetzt so ein Taste Circle, und du musst ja, du weißt ja nicht, ob süss direkt gegenüber von Ekel liegt. Dachte ich jetzt, ich bin einfach mal davon ausgegangen, dass süss und Eke komplementär sind. Da hast du bald nämlich wirklich die Häschen mit den Maden im Auge. Das willst du ja auch nicht. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Ich glaube, es gibt ja so einen gewissen Reset-Button bei YouTube und das ist K-Pop. Wenn du auch nur eine Sekunde K-Pop anschaust, dein Feed ist nicht mehr zu erkennen. Du bist in der Welt von K-Pop. Und immer wenn ich merke, ich habe mich zu sehr in eine Sackgasse manövriert, drücke ich den K-Pop-Button und bin dann zumindest in diesem sicheren Hafen, wenn ich auch nicht gerne bin, da muss ich mich auch wieder rausrudern, aber ich bin zumindest nicht mehr in der Hölle. Ne, genau, das ist ein überschaubarer Hafen. Das ist ein überschaubarer Hafen. Da weiß man, wo man ist. Ich kenne mich da mittlerweile auch ganz gut aus. Also ich kenne die Leute da. Ich bin so druselig, ich bin in eine neue Phase, keine Ahnung, dann bin ich in so einem YouTube gefangen und ich habe alles vergessen, was ich davor mochte. Ja, das stimmt. Alles vergessen und ich verbringe ja viel Zeit auf YouTube und bin da auch gerne, da gibt es ja auch tolle Sachen und so, die ich mal kannte, weiß ich aber nicht mehr. Ich kenne immer nur das, was ich gerade sehe. Das ist doch ein geiles Feature bei YouTube. Zeig mir den Feed von vor einem Jahr. Zeig mir mal die meistgeschautesten Videos von mir oder so die meistgeschautesten Genres von 2018. Ja. Und ich hatte ja auch eine gute Zeit. Viel Marble Olympics und so. War ja auch cool. Ich glaube, 2018, 2019 war ich auf dem Peak. Da war ich wirklich, da hatte ich den perfekten Feed und jetzt bin ich abgerutscht, bin abgedriftet. Aber ist gar keine schlechte Idee, so eine YouTube-Zeitmaschine. Das gibt es ja auch bei Spotify. Was hast du in dem Jahr gehört? Und auch bei YouTube, diese Videos haben dir vor zehn Jahren besonders gut gefallen. Ja, und dann so gesperrt, gesperrt, gesperrt, gesperrt, gesperrt, gelöscht, wegen Nacktheit gelöscht. Ja, das stimmt, das ist ein Problem, ja. Das ist ein Problem, aber... Unser YouTube-Account ist ja auch weg, unser YouTube-Kanal ist weg. Warum ist der weg? Das YouTube-Ufo ist weg. Ja, aber das YouTube-Ufo Folge 2 gibt es noch. Das YouTube-Ufo Folge 2 ist noch da, aber Folge 1 ist weg. Der YouTube-Kanal wurde gelöscht, weil ich urheberrechtlich geschützte Videos hochgeladen habe, gebe ich zu. Ich dachte aber, ich habe mir dafür extra einen neuen Kanal errichtet, aber stellt sich raus, wenn ein Kanal Ärger macht, dann wird der gesamte Account gelöscht, an dem noch andere Kanäle hingen, unter anderem unser das YouTube-UFO-Kanal, der ist jetzt weg. Unwiederbringlich weg. Man sagt jabringlich gelöscht weg. Man sagt ja, im Internet ist nichts wirklich
immer mal... Die Internet is written in
ink, Mark.
Stefan.
Nee, tut mir leid, in dem Sprichwort ist leider einfach
Mark mit drin.
Wenn the, if the
Internet is written in ink,
why is our
Video gone, Mark?
The Internet is not written in pencil,
it is written in ink, Mark. Yeah, but why is it gone then, Mark? Andrew, well, because I ripped out the page. I have to continue the fucking Aaron Sorkin-Dialog, that's not so easy. Yeah, you're right, it is written in ink. Yeah, okay, but we're not Sorkinesk.
Yeah, you're right, what you just said is true, but... But there's another thing to consider on top of what you just said.
And here it comes.
Here it goes.
Oh no.
Here comes the witty line.
Here it goes.
Watch out, watch out, be quiet, you don't want to miss it.
You don't want to miss it. There it is, three, two, one, witty, here it comes.
Yeah, it's written in ink, but there's also those ink eraser things.
Aber es gibt auch Tintenkiller.
Yeah, those ink killers, you know.
Jetzt weiss man das Wort nicht. Inker-Rey.
Dam, da-dam, da-dam, da-dam.
Hat in dem Jahr gewonnen gegen den Inception-Soundtrack.
Wahnsinn.
Trent Reznor von Nine Inch Nails.
Ist ein guter Film, kann man sich gerne anschauen.
Ich finde ihn gut, ohne ihn gesehen zu haben,
kann man auch mal wieder gerne reingucken.
Jetzt gerade tagesaktuell, Facebook ist abgestürzt. Schaut noch mal zurück, was ihr daran hattet und wie das alles angefangen hat. Schaut rein, Filmtipp von Florentin, The Social Network. Ja, und Bambi, welche ich auch noch gerne empfehle. Bambi, Shrek 2, das sind die Themen von Florentin. Ich möchte euch gerne die Serie The White Lotus ans Herz legen. Ja, die ist auch okay. Ja, die ist wirklich super super. Für und die habe ich sie auch empfohlen, aber auch hin und weg. Richtig toll, falls ihr euch fragt, Moment mal, warum tragen die im Winter beide Hawaii-Hemden, Goldketten und haben die Hawaii-Hemden viel zu weit offen, der Grund könnte die Serie The White Lotus sein. The White Lotus, fantastische Serie. Fantastisch! Fantastisch geschrieben, tolle Serie, toller Soundtrack. Viel Spass in der nächsten Woche und wir sehen uns dann auch wieder.
Tschau!
Sehen wir, mach's gut!
It's the worst bad production.